Oh
Bayern Munich dominates German club
football
now one of the world's most successful
clubs and biggest sporting brands the
trophy cabinet is packed
they hold the record 25 German titles
and 17 national cups they're five times
European champions and FIBA World Club
winners in 2013
this is their home ground for 75,000
seater
Allianz Arena opened in 2005 in cost 340
million euros to build it's hosted a
Champions League final and World Cup
games the club itself made 500 million
euros last year that's the third biggest
in sales when it comes to a club in
global football it also has been in the
black for 22 consecutive seasons that's
an exception not the norm in world
football last year
bian made 20 million euros in profit
1/5 of that came from selling
merchandise each year they sell around
1.7 million replica shirts that's more
than all the other Bundesliga sites
combined they gave us behind the scenes
access as we spoke exclusively to German
football legend and by Munich chairman
karl-heinz Rummenigge er as well as
Spanish World Cup winner shabby along
of this week's business of sport now
with Rama Nagar
over 300 appearances and 162 Gold's for
by noon twice the European Footballer of
the year
95 international caps and 45 goals for
West Germany Evans Col Heinz rumor [ __ ]
he's one of the biggest names in
European football
now he's back his chairman at the club
where he made his name English boots
affirm this week I sat down with him at
the club's headquarters its central noon
aching don't wanna loose of the rules of
football for an exclusive interview on
Bayan strategy
mr. uma daga thank you very much for
talking to us here at Bloomberg let's
start with the business side of a by
Munich last financial year you've
surpassed half a billion euros in
revenue for the first time you have
little debt you have local investors
how can you sustain this what seems to
be forever rise in revenues how can you
sustain this model so first of all I
believe it is very important having
success on the pitch and then we can
work about the success of the pitch I
believe by unfortunately was in the past
34 years very successful on the pitch
beginning in the 70s when we had the big
guys like Franz Beckenbauer get Miller
said Maya and so on on the page yourself
and and these team was very successful
winning three times in the row that
Champions League at that time and that
was a basis the roots of the clubs of
our club and then time by time we was
able to to have a kind of continuity on
the pitch and and we worked especially
in the past 10 years in partnerships
what we can do to have a stabilized
economy basis and so we we convinced
partners like adidas a 12 13 years ago
to be shareholder in by a Munich company
because we had the big project
the Alliance arena to build up and in
the meantime we we convinced to more
important partners like Audi and Aliens
insurance to be shareholder of buy
Munich and that that so we have a strong
basis on the pitch but I believe a
strong basis as well off the pitch so we
can be very optimistic looking in the in
the future if we split revenue into
three compartments there's matchday
broadcasting and commercial matchday you
lag behind four teams in Europe
which leads to the question could you
will you why don't you raise ticket
prices because to be a season ticket
holder at Bayern Munich it's it's
incredibly cheap versus Premier League
teams in England yeah should you could
you why don't you raise ticket prices to
to raise your matchday revenue so we're
we're as you said it's right we are much
cheaper than our friends in England
Italy Spain France as well so from the
big Five's way as the cheapest not just
buying alone the whole league is
relatively cheap in comparison to these
countries the problem of the problem is
is a kind of philosophy I would say so
we have the philosophy that the ticket
price is on it let's let's call it a
social basis so we want to care about
that if you go to buy Munich that at the
end is not depending just buy you your
pocket that you are able to get in
trance entrance in the stadium or not so
we have still I would say rich prices
regarding our lounges or business seats
where you pay for it for instance 12,000
euros per season but then we have as
well very social basis that the stands
just costing hundred fifty euros per
year for 70 games 17 games so we try to
have let's let's call it a social basis
between the rich and unfortunately not
the rich people that we care about that
I would say it is a kind of filthy
philosophy as well that the we don't
want to loose if the roots of football
football I believe is is belonging to
fans and the fans like to go into
stadiums and so we want to care about
that the fence are able to pay
relatively
let's call it good process and let's
talk about broadcasting because I think
when it comes to broadcasting rights
Bayern Munich in the top 20 clubs in
Europe its 10th 11th the German league
when you compare with justa Premier
League I mean it's it's lagging way
behind isn't it
can the German leak and the Bundesliga
whichever one can it close the gap when
it comes to broadcasting rights or not
why is there such a gap so first of all
we have an incredibly big gap between
pay TV England and pay TV Germany first
of all I believe we in Germany the leak
may make big mistakes if we talk about
10 12 15 years ago where where
pay TV market was established and then
build it and developed in England so we
was very slow believing that the clock
may be in Germany is going different
than in England but it doesn't go
different so that is a big big problem
now you see that in the actually
transfer market and because England have
so much of the English clubs have so
much money available in that market that
it is not easy to defend that we keep
our players as well here Bayern Munich
like Thomas Miller or like players from
Real Madrid like Sergio Ramos because
they have big requests from England and
so it is very difficult to keep them but
we have to do we have to do better in
Germany because it can't be it can't be
happen that just see Bundesliga the
first league is getting something like
half a billion euro income if you
compare that to the English market where
for instance the number 20 of the
Premier League is getting likely the
double of Bayern Munich as German
champion you can imagine how how long
these could work because especially in
the transfer market so I believe we are
very creative very good in sponsorship
very good in merchandise very good in
commercial your number two to PSG are we
are we are a very good
in these but so I believe the creativity
is quite limited in comparison to the
broadcasting money so we have to do much
better in Germany and that is really an
obligation for the German league to cash
in money in favour of the club's to to
be more come to to have a better
comparison against the English classes
Bayern Munich success has made them a
household name across Germany now
they're setting their sights on a global
fan base
the team has just returned from China
where they sold out stain that were
greeted by thousands of cheering fans
the fine Munich recently opening offices
in New York and Shanghai we asked Truman
eager about his plans for global
expansion the brand is very strong by
Munich it was number one
Manchester United overtook it last year
according to brand finance you will
you're the world's number two brand
that's based on a clubs ability to
monetize its global recognition what
more can buy nunik do to boost your
global recognition what would you say
the key is to harnessing your brand I
believe we are handed precent strong
regarding the home market in Germany I
believe everybody if you go on the
streets asking who is by a Munich
probably 100 percent can give you an
answer I believe what we are doing now
is to go abroad especially in the States
and in in Asia especially in Asia in
China because it's by far the biggest
market so we going there to bring the
club closer to offense in Asia and in
the States to to show the people that
buy what is buying unique for what
stands by a Munich and what is buy
Munich may be different than English
claps alike and what how are you
different I mean you were late to the
China party you've said that the Premier
League clubs were there way before you
you've now got a presence in China I
gather you're going to open an office in
Shanghai as I correct
let's Graham how can you show your
difference to the to the other big
European clubs who are already present
in China so I believe we can show our
different being different
because we just want to not go alone
therefore cashing money quickly so we
want to establish partnerships so we try
to get in close in closer partnerships
let's call it we want at the end of
course we want to earn money in depth
countries in that regions but we are
always ready to give up and to help them
in supporting football in their
countries I believe in the States
soccer is on a very good way football in
in China is on a good way but however
they need help to establish the quality
of these big quantity they fortunately
have available so I believe we can do a
lot for Chinese football we can do a lot
for American football and we try to do
so to help them at the end the outcome
has to be good for both for Bayern
Munich and for the football in the
States and in China do you worry about
China especially the headlines in recent
days it's it's an economy it's a market
system that's going through troubled
times - does that affect your supporter
on the ground or not no not really not
really absolutely no because when we had
our two of these here in China playing
in Beijing Shanghai and Guangzhou third
one so we had still the impression that
economy is a bit slowing in comparison
to the past years but and we had some
talks and discussions with partners who
followed us on that tour like Allianz
like Audi Volkswagen and so on and we
had the we had the clear sign however
that is a question of time now so maybe
after always growing growing growing
heav'nly growing maybe it's no a couple
of months hopefully just months that the
economy in China is slowing but no no no
worry about we are not worried about
what are the new markets you mentioned
the US you have an office in New York
outside the US outside China what are
the new markets that you're going to be
pushing into the untapped markets yeah
that bian has to be pushing into an
incoming ears
I can imagine that we go to a market
which maybe he's not very developed in
football on and not escape by many
football clubs like like India in there
is a big big market in the world many
many people are living there and
football is in comparison to hockey or
to other sports in India not very
popular but I believe there is still a
big market because they established a
leak last last season last year and I
believe that is something what we can do
together with our partners going there
together with editors with Audi with
aliens to - - to help Indian football to
develop that as well in our favor
can we talk about domestic matters once
again
the 50 plus 1 rule which to many English
fans is it's it's it's a strange rule
but it's quite simple the fans have to
be in control of 51% of each club there
are a few exceptions to this rule and
these exceptions is causing slight
annoyance among fans in Germany do you
do you underst do you accept the
annoyance I mean we're talking about
Hoffenheim here you know we're talking
about by Ally Baku sir nor Wolfsburg
people are looking at Leipzig Hannover
is the rule being diluted is it a bad
thing for football should the function
should the rule be banned
what's your view first of all from the
legal point of view this rule is not in
line with the low with the European law
doesn't work and so we had a case here
from Hannover but the Chairman or the
boss of innova was troubling that rule
and he was close to to open a legal case
in in Luxembourg at the ogia and I
believe fence like its likes it but they
love it and I had some some interesting
experience when we played I believe
quarter final two years ago in
Manchester so there had been many
supporters with a green and yellow shirt
that's right and I asked one of them
what is the reason that you were wearing
the green and yellow shirt and they said
so we don't like the Glazers we don't
like that they're that they take over
the club and and we don't like that and
so we don't want to help them buying the
original shirt and it was an interesting
experience for me and then and then they
said to me we laughed by a Munich
because you're independent so I believe
the supporters laughs in dependency of
the clubs is in a working financial type
like in Europe or not telling is the
truth it's very difficult to understand
actually financial fair play because
when I see the transfer activities from
certain clubs who had been penalized a
year ago yeah it's very difficult to
understand if financial fair play this
year is different and how it works and I
what I'm I'm missing a bit is a
transparency how it works because I
understand the rules but I don't
understand the rationality actually of
the whole system and that is not up to
me it's I received many telephone calls
what has happened in the market because
a year goes some clubs have been
penalized and now they came back
stronger than before and it's very
difficult to understand and I believe
it's up to you a fir to make it more
transparent and to make it more
understandable for the clubs
that was by Munich chief executive
officer karl-heinz Rummenigge up next I
speak to current player and Spanish star
Xabi Alonso he's won everything there is
to win on the pitch what about off the
pitch we speak about his investments and
his life after retirement shabby Alonso
has won it all from the World Cup
champions league titles at almost every
European trophy in between the Spaniards
been playing professionally for 16 years
and last year transferred to Bayern
Munich following the glitt'ring five
years at Real Madrid
we spoke exclusively with the Spanish
midfielder at baiance
training ground I asked him which league
is Europe's strongest it's been great
experience but not it's hard today which
one is the best of course I really liked
it primarily because it's the weights
it's been broadcasted all over the wall
and the weight you have to watch the
game and I finished potato probably is
the best like they both they're
primarily okay
I don't spectator front and on the
television front internationally can the
Bundesliga ever compete with the Premier
League in you look at the TV rights
money and the Premier League is way
ahead how can the Bundesliga catch up
how can buy a new Knick catch up with
the Manchester United's of this world
well I think that in our case
particularly biomimetic we can't compete
with all the teams financially talking
about because you see there they all the
income that they confirm from
merchandising Zonday from the stadium
from the civil rights and they have big
it's very well balanced but of course to
compete with the Premier League it's
really tough because they are years
ahead of of La Liga of Bundesliga in
terms of selling the TV rights in terms
of merchandising and all over the world
they have they have been doing this work
to have like an a worldwide brand for
years and I mean in dusters it's hard to
compete that I think that it's good that
the Bundesliga juggling for the last use
the teams the level of the team is
getting better which League to play next
or very silly well I don't know I don't
know I 33 now so the the end is getting
closer to getting closer I don't know
what is your final Club at the top or I
don't know I I don't who knows at the
moment I am focused on in this session
but but for sure and I will have to take
it would you be happy now having just
played in those three big leagues and
what I would like to add a little yeah
because she saw well so I'm fine happy
because you know I I love football and
out of there the the groups with big
tradition big history and so far I came
from social and my Holden
that's what I wanted to play after I
went to Liverpool you know all the
history Real Madrid tan Champlin and
coming here to buy a little acre a nice
mmm
and I scrape table for Gloria a butcher
that can you compete with Barcelona I
mean de de de were the team of yeah
Europe last you know the last year Real
Madrid before to Spain seemed to have
well actually the dominant team that the
Champions League
you wanted the year before Bayern Munich
is it going to be difficult to stop the
dominant Spain's hi Sarah fine now are
there in this sentence Chavez League
which is amazing isn't it yeah just but
of course it's gonna be tough because
once you are in the semi-final eyes you
know that what a final semifinals did
you know that you are going to face one
of the best things in Europe and
whenever you're paying Madrid or
Barcelona that they are fantastic
fantastic teams anything can happen but
we need to to get ready for that moment
but I wouldn't say that at the moment
there is Spain's dominance because
before the as you said the final was
between buyer and doorman yeah few years
ago since they were over their Premier
League team so pretty poorly the
football is has will a little bit like a
cycle there are cycles and there was the
privilege cycle the German one the
Spanish ones of the good thing is that
you don't see a clear favorite there are
five six top teams in Euro there for
sure contenders for the Champions League
you want everything literally World Cup
European Championships Champions League
National League's national cups what's
left what what keeps you going well you
literally want everyone is to wait for
say for me the most important is that is
it the collective accomplishments and
one but as an individual as a follower
you know I have that thing that
winded the third chaplet will the third
Club it will be like
like the ice on the cake to say no the
ice on the cake for me it will really
not only a shadow pass achieved Adam and
it will be great the achievement but
it's gonna be a different one I will try
that you've obviously been very
successful both on on the pitch and
financially you've been rewarded for
that our football players advised enough
on where to put their money how to
manage their money in your experience
would you say there's enough advice for
players
well prolly from it depends a lot off of
the background you have for how you are
raised you know I understand in some
cases is difficult to cope with with
that thing with that big money that
comes suddenly into your hands and to be
able to manage it in the right way
probably you are you don't have the
formation or your parents they don't
have the formation and that's why you
have to be surrounded with with great
advisors but it's difficult as well to
find that that people to trust your
money where you are going to put that
because from my case I was lucky enough
to my parent he was a football player as
well and we were led life we've had like
a good good advice also good a good chin
we've had so I've had no problems but
it's not easy to deal with that
- Dutch strong change to take an active
yes right it I take your body I mean you
keep healing yeah yeah yeah I try to
have a control of my finances to have
like a business plan because you know
that if you in ten years you get great
great amount of money but you need to
try to be smart enough to to be able to
not to to have enough rent and and not
return for the full of future as well
can you give us an idea mean well I try
to over so file on
on real estate or in the stalks of
Havana a nice portfolio to not to be hit
with this suddenly China crisis or to
with financial crises you to have a
diversified portfolio biology a of
global financial markets yes I do I do I
do keep an eye because I have some
investment in those in those areas and
you need to keep an eye on and as I said
before the end Paul is closer so I need
to be more more focus on those things of
the Spanish economy is rebounded are you
surprised it's it's the sort of the
strong economy right now in Europe on a
rural level the Grove values around
three three point three point three
percent so that's that's great news
because the the crisis hit really hard
Spain and you know the measure that had
to be taken we're really tough but of
course the macro numbers are are looking
really good for for Spain probably for
the people on the streets it's still
very hostile I the unemployment rate is
really high so it's it's it's not easy
to to differ for those people that but
probably in the Loden they will they
will notice that and hopefully not just
Spain and Europe will will get better
and that's going to be good
thank you very much thank you sweetie
goodbye one
you